hey folks it's q a Time 1 45. that's the
episode number and uh here we are
just the fact yeah well
just the actual fact yeah
yeah
okay
we're gonna start with this q a as we do
every week with a question from the
Discord server they vote on their
favorite their the question that they
most want answered this week every every
week how many times do I say a week a
lot uh it's not even every week because
like we didn't do a q a last week or two
weeks ago or something and anyway
I feel like I'm lying
lying is the new no
p-h-a-c-t-s is the new line
indeed yeah yeah okay question from
Discord this week
could you do a small section on
hamiltonian spite so when I first read
that I thought we were talking about
Hamilton the founding father I was like
oh I don't know I didn't know you wrote
about that and I didn't realize that
anyone really referred to
um spite this is not about Hamilton and
Burr and no no no it's it's about Game
Theory and um and you know prisoner's
dilemma and spite versus altruism and
all of this so
um that is the reference that is it's
W.D Hamilton not um Alexander
could you do a small section on
hamiltonian spite
it seems to be the driving force behind
many conflicts welcome us to some degree
the UK the Ukraine war in particular
if you listen to Putin Putin
no one pronounces it that way
if you listen to Putin's speeches when
they are translated
he openly States his goals are to
reshape the world order the West Reigns
over to do that he doesn't have to win
he has to lose less than the West does
that kind of hand also seems to yield an
advantage to people who are less
compassionate of their opponents
wondering if you were seeing the same
thing
so I will say just before you start
riffing
um I have not I have actively been not
paying a lot of attention to
um Ukraine and Putin or Putin
um
but assuming that this is an accurate
representation
um
I actually can't tell this is the
question asker or if Putin is saying
um in order to reshape the world order
if the West rans over he doesn't have to
win he has to lose less than the West
does
uh that's not spite that's just winning
by a different name right like spikes
right like the if if you if you win
um
by losing less than your opponent by by
knowing that you are seeking to lose
less than your opponent then that
doesn't fall into that that quadrant
on the Punnett square like thing that
you're drawing with regard to
um a dyadic game in which you can co-op
you can both cooperate or you can both
defect or one of you can cooperate into
fact or the other one you can to fact
and cooperate
yes my only concern about that I I'm not
going to address the Ukraine thing I I
don't understand the mapping and I don't
understand well enough what Putin is and
isn't saying and I know that I'm going
through a translation filter and so you
know how accurate is it uh there are too
many layers of uncertainty there okay um
I will say hamiltonian spite is a very
important concept to understand it's
actually very simple and it's not
um exotic and I think I think we may
have actually talked about this in a
previous uh podcast somewhere but it
doesn't matter uh let's put it this way
it is easy to understand when a person
behaves in a way that provides the
person choosing to behave in this way an
advantage and also provides another
person an advantage
right
even a selfish individual
will do things from which they get an
advantage irrespective of whether or not
they provide an advantage for another
person irrespective of whether that's
the intent
foreign
a person can also be easily understood
when they do something that provides
them the person choosing to do the
action with an advantage and a
disadvantages somebody else's standard
competition for example uh you would
Advantage yourself at cost to somebody
else
it is
um altruism
if you take a disadvantage to provide an
advantage to somebody else there are
reasons that this does evolve the most
obvious one is that your degree of
relatedness means that your genes are
doing themselves a favor even if you as
an individual are suffering a cost to
deliver a benefit to somebody else
Parenthood follows this model
we suffer costs as parents to Advantage
our children and the reason that we do
this evolutionarily speaking is because
that's because genes that cause us to
view the world this way
are passed on frequently the quadrant
that is difficult to explain
you can check that out
the quadrant that is difficult to
explain is I'm sorry I was distracted by
the strange animal noises going from
outside
um so what you're talking about with
regard to
um
I don't know whether that requires our
attention let's assume it does not until
we find out that it does okay so uh
Inclusive fitness being
um the form of altruism in which you are
doing something that benefits you kin
and there's also of course basically
um a situation in which you are social
and have long-standing social
interactions in which it may appear that
you are just being altruistic but there
is you know burn building being the
example that dick Alexander used to to
give primarily uh you know if if if you
are asked over and over again to help
your neighbors build barns that does not
necessarily mean that you are an
altruist or a fool uh it does mean that
at the point that it's time to build a
barn on your property you expect
rightfully uh that others will come and
join in yeah so there are a bunch of
different uh
categories of altruism that are easily
explained
one of them is reciprocal altruism
another is indirect reciprocity which is
what you have just described in which
you invest in a system in which you take
more out than you have invested and so
it's not beneficial even if you don't
get your favor from the same people to
whom you did a favor
all these things are relatively
comprehensible the perplexing one that
the the question here is targeted at yep
is when you accept a cost to deliver a
cost
why would you ever accept a cost to harm
someone else and the answer is there's a
very good evolutionary reason to do this
and many of the most important features
of civilization actually depend on it
being done and the point is when
somebody is not behaving according to
the rules that govern some collective
the rules that a lineage abides by for
example
than if they profit in doing so then
their betrayal of the collective
will uh be
favored by selection and so it will
happen increasingly much
so in order for that not to be true what
you have to do is change the calculus
for the person who has betrayed the
collective so that it did not turn out
to be not beneficial and what this means
is
you will
for example
um
let's say that your child has
misbehaved in a supermarket
and you yell at the child in such a way
that makes you ugly in the eyes of
others in order that the child feels
humiliated so the child will not do this
in the future the point is you have
accepted the the cost of schooling the
child
likewise and the most obvious example of
spite in the sense which is to accept a
cost in order to deliver a cost
is policing that we
um
pay to have a police force that makes it
expensive to commit crime right how
expensive well ideally what you want to
do is invest enough that crime doesn't
pay if crime doesn't pay then uh you
don't expect to see it flourish and
spread right if you want crime to you
it'll never be zero but the point is
anybody who engages in crime if on
average they do worse because they
engaged in crime they will find
productive things to do if they
sometimes come out ahead because they've
engaged in crime such that that can be a
viable Niche then you expect to see it
so we collectively have to invest enough
in inflicting costs that is to say in
policing and prisons and other forms of
punishment
such that crime doesn't pay and that's
what drives crime down
I mean maybe so the connection
that you're making there between
policing and Spite and this rendering of
of Putin perhaps just looking to reframe
the world even if his own country comes
out less well ahead by most standard
metrics
um is interesting because it all relies
on there being
some other measure by which the
individual who is losing is actually
getting something out of the situation
well I don't think it can be the correct
interpretation if if Russia actually
loses
or it can be expected to live especially
but if they if they gain if they gain by
reframing the the world order if they
gain in the long even even if uh the
experience an immediate economic
downturn and their sanctions because
everyone hates rushing down all of this
then that is that is a win and there's
so you know there's not only a temporal
uh the axis to consider but also a
actually maybe the values that you are
measuring spite on aren't the same
values that the actor is measuring them
on
well you get into a difficult problem
when
um
the two parties are working in a
different currency we sometimes saw this
there's a documentary you're not talking
about monetary currency you're talking
about metaphorical currency whatever
they value yeah
um
there was a a documentary about
um
I don't even remember exactly it was
Loosely about atheism that included uh
Dawkins I think Dawkins was sort of the
central focus of the documentary and I
remember a case in which he was arguing
with a creationist
and
you know from the perspective of a
rationalist materialist Dawkins was
thrashing this guy just mercilessly but
from the point of view of this guy's
constituency was quite the opposite
Dawkins was making a fool out of himself
and so in that case it's very hard to
know how to evaluate you know both it
makes sense that both parties would
choose to engage in that debate because
nobody lost everybody played to their
own audience and won and uh you know so
anyway what does one make of that it's
not hard to explain why a person uh
would cater to their own I mean I'm not
arguing that Dawkins was doing anything
cynical I think was doing exactly what
he does earnestly but in this case
it was just apparent that as much as to
Dawkins it felt like he was delivering
this guy a painful loss that was not
what was going on interesting um
so anyway I would say that you know the
calculus of spite requires that you are
suffering a cost in terms that you
recognize in order to deliver a cost to
somebody in terms they recognize in
order to shape their behavioral
landscape so they stop engaging in some
behavior that they engaged in before and
you know that is a perfectly plausible
interpretation I do whatever Putin may
be I do think he is
um a Russian Patriot right I do think he
wants whether that's yeah whether it's
for selfish reasons or not whether he
wants his legacy to be improving the
standing of Russia in you know in the
world
um as long as that's what he's doing and
the point is I'm willing to suffer costs
in order to get there then yeah that's
following
um the hamiltonian spite doesn't mean
you know obviously there's a question
about I'm choosing to engage in this
Behavior
because I expect this to be the result
of it doesn't mean that that is what the
result of it is you know it could be
that Russia ends up way behind as a
result of this action even though uh the
people in this case the person who chose
to take the action expected otherwise
yep
good next question all right
the discussion of gender dysphoria as an
ancient problem not traditionally
treated by medically transitioning
raises a conundrum
how does one evaluate medical
interventions through an evolutionary
lens modern medicine saves lives that
would have been lost how to tell what is
beneficial versus counterintuitive
and then this person has another
question in the spirit of chesterton's
fence what are your thoughts on Bill
Gates intention to eradicate mosquitoes
deepest respect I've learned so much
from the both of you uh let me start
with with the eradication of mosquitoes
which I think we have talked about
before
I didn't actually know it was part of
the the gates goal um but I've heard it
from a variety of people
uh and every time I hear it I think I
wonder if the person saying it has any
idea how many species of mosquitoes
there are and I'm pretty sure that I've
never heard this proposed by someone who
actually understands biology at a level
that would be warranted to make such a
claim
um you know I don't I don't think that
these claims of bringing back the woolly
mammoth are legit for different reasons
but at least the woolly mammoth was a
species right that does have a close
close issue you don't think it's
acceptable to do it or you don't think
it's plausible I didn't say acceptable I
don't think you said legit I'm just
trying to figure what you mean um I
don't think it's gonna happen I know I
think when you look at what they're
actually claiming to do yeah they're not
oh
um cool stuff happening at the window
yeah
um
um I just when you actually look what
they're doing they're not actually
talking about bringing back of the
woolly mammoth that's so I I question
those claims for different reasons
um then oh what we need to do is
eradicate the mosquito the mosquito not
a thing so there is a clay to mosquitoes
also pretty specios
um anopheles that are in fact
responsible for vectoring most of the
diseases that are known to be mosquito
vectored I think aity is I'm not
actually sure to pronounce it aedes is
another smaller plate of mosquitoes it
also vectors some but anopheles Vector
malaria and Dengue and yellow fever and
zika and on and on and on and on a bunch
more than I'm just not remembering at
the moment and I don't know how you
would but at the very least any any
proposal that begins with eradicate the
mosquito has revealed such a naivete
about what is actually going on that you
should not trust those people right but
even we don't even know whether or not
this is the Gates Foundation saying
eradicate the mosquito or this is
somebody uh
doing shorthand on sure you know and I'm
not making I'm not taking a position on
that so that's that's point one is that
if someone does say oh we just want to
eradicate the mosquito then you know
you know that they don't really they're
talking about I've heard people say
eradicate it would be all right to
eradicate mosquitoes that's what they
say which is tantamount to the same
thing yeah from my perspective it's the
same thing
um if you were able to collapse it down
to still a gigantically large number of
individuals and still a fairly large
number of species of mosquitoes that are
actually known to Vector diseases that
um that cause a tremendous amount of
human disease and death
I'm still not sure you should
and I'm specifically not sure you can
but at least now we're in the realm of
maybe we can talk about this
now I what I don't know
I don't know a lot of things but one
thing I don't know is in those places
where anopheles exist for instance in
tropical Latin America
where there are all of those diseases
that are vectored by
um by anopheles mosquitoes I don't know
what fraction of the biomass of
mosquitoes is made up by monopolies
so the fact is that bats and other
insectivorous animals including many
birds rely on mosquitoes
to exist and if you take out a giant
chunk then you're starting to lose
insectivorous
birds and bats and then you're starting
to lose the organisms that eat those and
you know pretty soon you have a trophic
Cascade that has collapsed
if anopheles are
two percent of the biomass of the
mosquitoes in the places where they
exist maybe you could do that without
effect
maybe not
how is it that we are actually supposed
to make these assessments
um it's it's entirely going to be
theoretical models because you can't
actually do it unless you've done it and
then um then you've got a potentially a
problem so I I worry about interventions
like this but yeah I worry about them
too uh I think I worry about them less
because I think you know this strikes me
as the hubris that nature always teaches
us we're not going to be able to do it
right you're not gonna be able to do it
it doesn't mean you won't do tremendous
harm in the attempt yeah but look there
are several Dimensions here that I want
to just point out need to be explored
and even to begin to answer the question
of whether this would be a reasonable
thing to attempt
one is what would the net effect be on
human suffering
I don't know you know we have an overly
simplistic view of the universe
a huge number of people die of malaria
and yellow fever and other diseases born
by anopheles mosquitoes
If you eliminate those mosquitoes and
therefore presumably those diseases
what happens to those people
presumably different people die of
different things
does the human population go up because
fewer people are dying in malaria or
does starvation go up because there are
more mouths to feed because you haven't
addressed you've addressed the malaria
problem and but you've you know it's an
open equation so I don't you know from
the point of view of are you willing to
end a clade of mosquitoes to decrease
human suffering and death of course
is that the effect that would come from
eliminating those mosquitoes no clue
could be worse
are you capable of doing that thing and
if you could do that thing would
accomplish the goal that you said that
you're trying to obtain and the answer
to both of those questions maybe no
right yeah also what kind of harm I mean
we've watched
um
absolute numb skulls
double down so many times on their
idiotic plans surrounding covid yeah one
of those numbskills being the very same
numsical in question here with respect
to dealing with anopheles mosquitoes
right right so the point is okay suppose
we grant that you should eliminate an
awful these mosquitoes
and then you try and lo and behold
evolution is quicker than you are and it
doesn't work and so you start turning up
the dose of whatever you're using or the
intensity of the attack or whatever it
is you're doing at what point do we able
to do we get to say look you were a
dummy for thinking you could do that and
you're doing all of this harm in the
attempt and it isn't working you know
how much cost are you inflicting on the
world for your uh for your arrogance so
before you continue I want to come back
also to the first part of this question
but the very next question actually is
relevant to where you were just going
which is the brown stink bug has invaded
the Pacific Northwest this year
um and this year is the worst yet
scientists talk of releasing Samurai
wasps to combat them well more invasive
species migrate and does introducing a
non-native Predator work so this is the
same sort of like okay we're gonna do
this thing are we gonna do this other
thing to correct the failures or the not
quite living up to potential the first
intervention yeah on every one of these
instances in which you get clever about
oh we'll release the so-and-so to catch
the such and such Doesn't work I don't
know why she swallowed the fly right
manatees didn't control hydrilla in the
Panama Canal uh Mongoose didn't control
rats in Jamaica this never freaking
works now it's not to say that there's
no plan that could work but the basic
problem is anytime you do this you get a
predator prey oscillation right as the
prey becomes sufficiently rare the
Predator Gets rare because it's got
nothing to eat either that or it's
eating something else you didn't want it
to and so it's not a good plan which is
often what happens you bring in this
Predator like well and it's native
habitat loves this like well it's a
native habitat it doesn't have filet
mignon hey look what it's got here so it
starts taking off so the newly
introduced thing leaves the original
introduced thing alone which then
thrives and this now opens up more Niche
for that guy because it's now eating a
bunch of the Native um prey items yeah
so look invasive species are a problem
we do a terrible job of controlling them
the way to deal with it is to control
them and then coming in after the fact
with your clever pesticide or predator
or whatever it is is uh it's a sign that
you've lost
um it's not to say that there's no case
where it has worked but it you got to
have a really good plan
um the other thing I would say though is
let's say that you found that anopheles
mosquitoes were a significant
fraction of the mosquito biomass in some
habitat yep well a you've got they might
be but B most likely thing that happens
if you were to push a button and have
them disappear is a bunch of things that
they were out competing
grow in other generative mosquitoes
filled in it or it might not be
mosquitoes but the point is will you
change the admixture of the vertebrates
yes you will
if what you've done is introduced a
pesticide that goes after anopheles
mosquitoes and is not terrifically
targeted in some way that pesticides
never are
plausible you could but if you pesticide
your way towards the elimination of the
anopheles mosquitoes I think you will
see an environmental catastrophe but it
won't be a lack of mosquito catastrophe
it will be a pollutant catastrophe so
but what you're arguing is if you if you
could if we could successfully Target
anopheles mosquitoes only
and
uh and otherwise leave the ecosystem
unperturbed that something would fill
that anopheles Niche without inherently
being a vector for yellow fever or
Dengue or malaria or anything absolutely
um which then perhaps the bats are
reading the mosquitoes the birds between
the mosquitoes could eat or not as well
and so you'd get selection on the bats
to move into a slightly different
morphology to better eat the new things
in the space or you get some of those
bats dying off and being replaced by
different bats who are better at doing
something else ultimately you've got
traffic levels and you've got a certain
amount of productivity and then at each
level of the trophic hierarchy you've
got some number of Critters profiting as
much as can be done off of the level
below it and uh so Something's Gonna
Fill it and it could make you a lot less
happier it could you know be delightful
and if you could magically go like
anophe is gone like no no toxins no no
nothing if there there was an anopheles
gone button would it be worth risking
pushing it I think absolutely does that
mean it would be okay in the end no it
might be a negative change on the other
hand do you think that risk would be
worth taking even if it was truly an
anophe is gone if it was an awfully it's
gone button with no other consequences
then yes I don't trust the people who
formulate these plans
they claim they have such buttons and
they don't right
um yes that's exactly right but
what I would and I fully acknowledge
that there is a risk
that you eliminate the anopheles
mosquitoes you eliminate the malaria and
the amount of human suffering goes up
because you didn't understand that as
bad as malaria is that's the number of
people who were going to die of
something was close to fixed and you
changed what they died of and it was
worse right
um that's possible so I would say even
given that risk I still think the
chances that you improve overall human
well-being by eliminating malaria it
would be worth the risk of altering the
habitats in which these mosquitoes exist
but all of that said I do think there is
an overarching way to do this properly
and it makes almost everybody uh at
least annoyed at me this argument is
very annoying and I get why it is
but the argument is this
the only
actually
grounded way to decide what we shouldn't
and shouldn't do
is to forego the idea that other
creatures have rights and calculate
everything backwards from Human
well-being right now I know that this is
a terrible terrible argument because
when I look at an orca or an elephant or
a chimpanzee or a gorilla or a lion or a
wolf or any of those other creatures and
I hear that they don't have the right to
exist that it's all about us
I know that there's something morally
offensive about that however my point
would be as soon as you say well the
right of orcas to exist is obvious
so we must defend it then you get
immediately to the question of well why
doesn't malaria have a right to exist
right where are you going to draw the
line of which creatures do have a right
to exist and which creatures are we
allowed to get rid of right and my point
is that is a Fool's Paradise where you
are going to end up in a bunch of
arguments we don't have the information
in order to draw the lines cleanly and
so
the surprising thing is if you say well
human well-being is the thing to
maximize
but you do it right and the point is not
just current human beings but human
beings forever indefinitely into the
future
do those human beings have a right to
see orcas or do we have the right to
exterminate the orcas or behave in ways
that will result in the elimination of
the Orca absolutely those future humans
have the right to a world with orcas in
it and rhinoceroses and gorillas and
wolves and all those other creatures do
they have a right to a world with
anopheles mosquitoes well no presumably
enough these mosquitoes are not going to
become a benefit to humans the only way
that they're a benefit to humans is if
the ways that people die get worse if
you eliminate those mosquitoes which we
don't have reason to think is true so
the point is if you want to figure out
what what shouldn't what should and what
should we not do
the line is
do you have enough information to assert
from the present position in history
that a certain change will be a net
benefit to humanity which we will assume
is indefinitely long-lived right if the
answer to that is yes then that's a
change worth gambling on if the answer
to that is
no the risks are that we will make life
worse and that life will be permanently
worse because you will eliminate orcas
and every
human generation from now on will live
without them and that will be very bad
right then you don't make the change and
this is not and you know I guess the
point is my instincts as a bleeding
heart liberal
that there are creatures that we ought
to protect for their own sake and that
habitats are beautiful and we ought to
protect them and that we ought to be
very cautious about changes that we're
going to make thinking we're going to
improve things all of those values are
actually protected best when you say
human well-being in the long term is the
only parameter to maximize but you have
to do so in a wise way in which you do
not make stupid changes that turn out to
create unintended consequences right you
have to be certain enough of your
ability to do X and not do other things
that are going to swamp out that benefit
all of the values that I hold dear are
actually best protected by this one
annoying uh shift to actually human
well-being is the only thing we should
be paying attention to
well as you know I don't like it but I
don't have anything better
so that's where we are that's where I've
been when I've heard you give that
before yeah yeah well I mean that's
where I am too I don't like it either
but uh but I don't have anything better
okay so as for the first part of the
question how does one evaluate medical
interventions by an evolutionary lens
um we go into this a fair bit and must
be like chapters three and four of
hunter-gatherer's guide
to the 21st century
um
and you know darwinian medicine briefly
seemed like it was going to be created
and and have a have a place you know it
would be evolutionary thinking would be
taught in medical schools uh following
the publication of the Williams and
Nessie book
um
why we get sick why we get sick that's
it in like 1994 or something like that
um and then it just I mean that book's
still great and it's classic now and it
needs a bunch more updates and a bunch
more people thinking that way and there
are a few
um but by and large medical schools
don't have anything about thinking
evolutionarily and frankly all you have
to do is go on the side of the AMA
Over The Association of Pediatrics or
the endocrine whatever any of these
people and you see very clear evidence
that I mean to hell would think and
evolutionarily they can't even think
scientifically so I mean it's a really
shouldn't be a high bar at all to expect
people who you want to help you live a
long and healthy life to understand
something about where you came from for
those hundreds of millions of years but
nope can't do that no sir so uh anyway
we go into it a bit and and go through
some of the mistakes that um Western
medicine is made through a combination
largely of hubris and reductionism and
over-reliance on scientism and over
Reliance on technology
yeah and in the modern era over Reliance
on fauci is not helping no it's really
not um yeah yeah yeah
so we're a long ways in we've only done
two questions yeah I would just say
three it's three
the problem
as
uh
Steve Patterson points out
at the root of a huge number of failed
Fields is an under appreciation of
complexity
and I would argue the reason we
under-appreciate complexity is that we
succeeded in science
in the simple Fields first simple
doesn't mean easy to understand but
simple means fundamental right because
we succeeded in physics and chemistry
first we are late to the game with
respect to complex systems and when
you're in a complex system and you've
got something functional you ought to be
very cautious about disrupting it
and you ought to be very careful to
monitor
the cascading effects that flow from
whatever alteration it is and that's
true whether you're talking about
habitats as we were with the anopheles
mosquitoes or the intervention in a body
with medicine the the best policy is
intervene as little as you can
and
that's how you should evaluate these
things the fact is delaying an
intervention and looking skeptically at
it when you don't know very much about
what its actual implication is uh is
enough to get you there and then when
you realize that we know for sure that
you are interfering with normal
reproductive structures the basic point
is look these interventions to the
extent that they interfere with those
things are a violation of the
Hippocratic Oath pure and simple why are
we suddenly so comfortable why do we not
even mention the Hippocratic Oath when
talking about these interventions so the
question was not about Trans in
particular at all
um oh no no it did ask about that it
asked about
in the context of uh the interventions
that we were discussing in the main
podcast but anyway
the gender assigned at Birth may be a
perversion of and God said
James Lindsay and others have noted that
the God of this new religion is one's
self
thoughts
that's fascinating I had not heard James
say that I'm not I've not heard that
before
um that does sound like his kind of
insight and it also fits really well
with uh Aaron reich's observations that
we were that I was reading from in the
first hour
about the rise in sort of the focus on
self and frankly becoming disembodied
um around you know the early modern age
and um
and that fitting with also a rise in
depression
uh it's fascinating I haven't I haven't
heard this before yeah there's something
to it I think there's also something to
the idea
um it's amazing how frequently somebody
who has an organic mental disorder like
a very serious one like schizophrenia
will conclude that they are in fact an
agent of God or that they are you know
Jesus returned or something like this
and I'm wondering if there's not
at the point that the
your evaluative structures have failed
sufficiently
if you don't have a hemorrhage of
overfitting where the idea is you start
validating a world view in which you
have
tremendous capacity of insight and the
power to alter things that a mortal
wouldn't think they had the power to
alter that basically the postmodernism
leads you to
if you if you if you're not grounded by
something it leads you to a
um an absurd level of belief in your own
comprehension and uh insight
and that that's not I think that's
effectively synonymous with what it
sounds like James is arguing oh I don't
think so I don't think it's synonymous
at all actually I was going to say I
think that yours is an individual level
argument and his is a population level
argument if if I understand what is
being said here correctly that the God
of this new religion is oneself so he's
talking about you know the understanding
that what is taking over is this sort of
wokeness this ideology whatever at a
religion level and you're talking about
sort of the psychological thing that can
happen to people as they experience
X Y or Z be it organic mental disorder
or you know looking at itself in the
mirror too long or being too much on
Tick Tock or whatever it is
so that's curious because the idea that
the God of this new religion is self
you're you're making
itself like your culture
no because you said that I was making an
individual level thing and you thought
that James was because he's taught
because this appears to be about the
religion about the the religion that has
as many gods as they're our members yeah
but I think there's something there's
something interesting here without
I'm not I'm not sure how deep it might
go because I guess it will require uh
pinpointing like okay where do you want
to stand to assess this do you want to
stand at the individual and try to
understand the psychology do you want to
stand the level of society and say I
want to understand how this really how
this new religion really has taken over
but we have yeah a lot more questions so
let's proceed
um
I need dating advice not for me but for
my nephews who are college-aged it seems
like the girls they meet are woke and
entitled
what advice do you what advice do you
give to your boys foreign
well among other things
at one of ours is sitting right here
producing the podcast so uh
I have to adhere to advice I've
been yeah I would say the advice I
believe I have given Zach and Toby is a
that they should that the Rarity of
people who have the characteristics one
would want in a mate is sufficient that
you should be very careful not to assume
oh you're gonna date for a while and
then you'll settle down you'll find
somebody blah blah blah you never know
when you're gonna meet that person and
don't [ __ ] it up because the
worthy mates are not a commodity at this
point they really aren't maybe they
never were but they aren't now that's
for sure
I have said
never consider
um marrying somebody who does not have a
sense of humor about themselves
the sense of humor about oneself is so
important to navigate the difficulties
of forging a relationship with somebody
that it is an absolute deal breaker if
somebody doesn't have it no matter what
other characteristics they may have
um
I would add because this is specifically
saying the girls they beat are woke and
entitled and yep uh but
people who know how to do real physical
things in the universe are less likely
to be woken entitled at least at a
global scale
so
um meeting people on an adventure you
know backpacking hiking or learning a
physical skill like carpentry or
mechanics or you know something
um any anyone who is who is willingly
and is interestedly engaging in such
things is going to have a very hard time
hanging tight to their wokeness at least
at least across all demands yep
um
yeah and I would say a corollary of that
is spend as much time as you can in
those activities that would reveal those
kinds of instincts and skills it's you
know it's like the opposite of a
uh
a singles
bar right spending time in the
activities where you might meet somebody
who has the characteristics that make
sense
um
it is a good it's a little bit like it's
tough though I mean precisely for for
young men
um because the activities that we're
talking about
um are now and have historically been
more likely to be of interest to young
men
yeah um and so you know the sex ratio is
going to be pretty skewed to start
yep
so that means be awesome so that that
sex ratio is not an obstacle to winning
the heart of the right person yeah
um
yeah I mean I would also just add this
is not directly responsive but I would
also say
um uh among the pieces of advice I know
I've given
um
don't sleep with people that you know
are not marriage material which doesn't
mean that you're expecting to marry
somebody at the point that you go to bed
with them but it means that it's not
cool going to bed with somebody who's
already
uh for whom you already know that
there's a deal breaker
foreign
next question
Tesla has a question yes he has many
questions
how much of you two thought about suing
YouTube or at least filing foia requests
regarding your demonetization government
apparently had a hand in censorship at
Twitter maybe here too
I have no doubt that the government had
a hand and I have no doubt that in a
world in which courts still functioned
properly that
the revelations that would flow from
discovery
would
benefit the world and would
uh restore our ability
to earn that would be very positive
the problem is
you are talking about a landscape that
is heavily stacked in favor of a
corporation that you know not only can
spend indefinitely much to make sure the
effort comes to nothing
uh but has a permanent legal staff of
gargantuan size it's not to say that an
effort couldn't be won
but it's to say
uh in signing up for such a thing
one has to do so very soberly so believe
me I believe they are absolutely
vulnerable on a Level Playing Field this
would be the obvious remedy the playing
field isn't level and that makes it a
different calculation but no it's very
much on the table
foreign
this is an observation with a link that
we have not gone to I watched a Cooper's
Hawk take a Flicker and two Pileated
woodpeckers came and harassed the
Cooper's Hawk
wow and
um he's got a link on Flickr spelled
differently
um video altruism reciprocal altruism
question mark
that's amazing so just for those for
those who don't know birds at all
flicker flickers a woodpecker flickers
and pleated woodpeckers are pretty
closely related
um but not the same species obviously
yeah I don't know that they're I bet
they're not closely related within
woodpeckers but both being woodpeckers
they're relative I mean all the all the
northern temperate woodpeckers are
fairly close uh because they're just all
right they're flickers and and uh
Affiliated so close but it doesn't
really matter that that is pretty
clearly not what's going on yeah um I I
wasn't suggesting this was some kind of
Inclusive fitness thing yep
so
all right let's let's put a couple
things on the table here one there's a
very interesting phenomenon called
Predator inspection
which causes creatures when one creature
is captured by a predator I would just
like it noted that Tesla did not make
that happen no he didn't
um he may have willed it to happen yeah
I mean he's being opportunistic now but
he didn't he didn't ask for that but
when
a creature is captured by a predator
other similar creatures will often show
up to see what's happening
and this makes a brutal kind of sense
if you want to know if you want to
develop a search image for the thing
that threatens you if you want to have
information about what it eats
seeing it provides that so this has
interesting ramifications back when I
was doing that work
it was well known that you might have a
net that you had placed a mistnet and it
might be getting little or no traffic
and then a bat would fly into it start
screaming and then suddenly it would
fill with bats all right other bats are
coming to look
um so that does not get to the answer to
your question if the pileateds were
actually harassing
the predator
then
that's different than investigating it
it's not an informational thing they're
actually taking a risk to inflict a cost
um
there are relationships I know of
nothing in the neighborhood of flickers
and Pileated woodpeckers but
there are things like mixed foraging
flocks in which birds will
who uh travel together multiple species
of birds will travel together and forage
together typically this works best if
they eat different things so you can
imagine that if you ate insects but you
ate different insects than some other
bird then the size of the flock provides
some protection
the extra eyes that come from another
animal that can see a predator and may
have different visual Acuity provides
some safety so there's lots of reasons
that different species might gather
together to forage and get an advantage
from larger numbers of individuals from
other species being present one could
imagine therefore that if the Pileated
and the flicker were getting an
advantage from
foraging together which they might
because they do eat different things
that uh the Pileated if it could
relatively safely punish the Predator
into releasing the flicker if that
flicker is a flicker that those
particular Pileated woodpeckers have
been traveling with then there's a
selfish reason they might do it
um
it could be that there's an argument
if you imagine that this Predator I was
doing a woodpecker full actually sorry
if you imagine that this predator
is one that's going to stick around
where it's making a profit and the
pileateds have a nests with chicks in it
and therefore making driving the
Predator's profit uh you know so it's in
the it's in the red
uh would cause it to move on to a
different habitat and the chicks of the
pileateds would therefore have an
advantage you could imagine it making
sense in those ways so anyway I don't
know that any of these things are what's
going on but my only point is that proof
of concept wise there are a number of
ways you could get to it being in the
interest of Affiliated woodpeckers to
punish or harm the Predator that was uh
eating a flicker
um in their own territory and those
hypotheses make predictions too I do
um so
I can't
in the amount of time I had I figured
exactly how close they are but um
the genus that pileateds are in and the
genus that flickers are in are in a
tribe uh that is five Genera strong
within woodpeckers so they're not that
distant with a woodpeckers but I don't
know how many species each of those
each of those General have got it anyway
I did not mean to suggest that there was
this is going to be about Inclusive
fitness just it's interesting that it's
a woodpecker that got taken into larger
bodied woodpeckers came and
harassed the Predator yep
seems PayPal is switching accountability
to the stakeholders as opposed to the
shareholders
ESG question mark I don't know what that
means I noticed PayPal was the only
option here to submit will you add other
options I'm closing out PayPal so that's
a question about specifically the Q a
yeah well I think if PayPal does not
relent we're going to have to figure out
some way uh to avoid using them and
frankly it makes sense for their
business to evaporate upon taking such
an egregiously stupid and immoral
position yep
um
the other question I guess was ESG
um
what is that what is that I have
forgotten what it's it's an acronym for
environmental sustainably
sustainability and yeah it's actually
one of you can have it here in a second
environmental social and governance yeah
so it's a score I think
um that is being
pouted as advancing socially responsible
capitalism it is of course a
Scourge and it is
one of these utterly ironic
phenomena that is going to make the
world worse and not better
but yes in some sense
however this is working if this is an
internal mob that's getting PayPal to do
something fiscally stupid because nobody
will take responsibility for telling the
woke Bob inside PayPal to go to hell
or if it is Paypal trying to earn an ESG
score for some
fashionable purpose in the market I I
don't know but yes it's something in
that neighborhood
next question in my understanding both
mRNA and classical vaccines work by
making the body produce viral proteins
which then trigger an immune response
why is one riskier than the other
because that's not how classical
vaccines work vaccines classical
vaccines don't quote make the body
produce viral proteins they introduce
viral proteins for instance or entire
viruses or you know whatever it is
that you are trying to develop an
immunity against
that itself triggers the immune response
so making your body into a factory that
produces the pathogen is quite different
from introducing small mats to the
pathogen either intact or not itself
yeah I can make uh I I can Steel Man the
argument
um in the sense argument that classical
vaccines make the body produce viral
proteins yeah because a live attenuated
does in a sense live attenuated
um basically uses a a real virus to
infect cells that then produce
um I still wouldn't making the body
produce like allowing the body to be a
host to a pathogen yep look there's no
question that these vaccines are
radically different and they are
radically different in several ways and
there's a distinction between the DNA
version and the RNA version
um the turning your cells into a factory
for a viral protein
is utterly novel turning your cells into
a factory for a viral for a viral
protein that is itself cytotoxic is
mind-bogglingly stupid
um you could say that you and I have and
I've been accused of misinformation for
claiming that this thing is cytotoxic
but it obviously is which is now well
known
um but nonetheless
point being there is much that is
different here let's take the
mRNA version of this the mrnas are a
hyper stabilized with pseudo-eurydines
meaning that the normal process by which
mrnas are taken apart does not function
normally which makes the normal the
normal mechanisms by which the body
would dismantle mrnas that it found
floating in the intercellular fluid
right or would take apart mrnas uh in
the cytoplasm of a cell right these
these are not supposed to be long-lived
molecules or oh yes right okay um they
have been made very long-lived which is
having
many effects that are probably related
to the syndromes that people are getting
after mRNA vaccination what's more the
lipid nanoparticle mechanism for getting
the mrnas into cells in the first place
have no targeting mechanism and the fact
that they are not targeted by remaining
in the part of the body where they're
injected means that this is just a it's
haphazardly introducing mrnas into cells
around the body that then become
uh antigen factories which then causes
the body to react to them in an immune
fashion that presumably results in the
destruction of those cells it's really
an insane plan
so that's a little bit related to this
question
have you seen the covid vaccines under a
microscope which I actually have not
what's your opinion on nanotech found in
vials compared to Scientific literature
on nanotech
I think what's probably being said is
that there's a cartoon version of the
thing and then there's what you actually
get in some vial that came off some
assembly line uh and has been shaking
around and exposed to who knows what and
the basic point is you've got a slurry
in which some of the things probably
look something like what's in the
brochure but
um
you're injecting you know just as
you may have an idealized sense of
what's in an oil deposit that then
results in you getting uh gasoline and
all of the other things that
fractionation produces an oil deposit is
a
slurry of every conceivable organic
compound you could get from taking those
it doesn't come out pre-fractionated
yeah it's pretty messy yeah with a lot
of pollutant from any perspective so
yeah look
the more one understands about
especially the MRNA version of these
vaccines
the more alarming the plan
is
um
there's as soon as you know
that
the protein in question is bioactive
that
it's going to be produced arbitrarily in
the body because the lipid nanoparticles
don't have a targeting mechanism
uh that the lipid nanoparticles
themselves have a chemical implication
in the body that is not positive
as soon as you know how radical this
plan was it's a non-starter right it's
hard to imagine the
uh scenario in which it would have been
worth taking an experimental medication
like this the DNA ones
better
because they have a targeting mechanism
but and they don't have mRNA so it's not
stabilized with pseudo-uridine that's
two arguments in its favor on the other
hand it does produce a cytotoxic antigen
by hijacking your cells
and you know it's it's Leaps and Bounds
better without being anywhere near good
yep
which isn't to say this wasn't brilliant
it was brilliant it just this stuff was
not ready to be injected into a human
yep
you've said that trans exists
historically doesn't this just boil down
to people dressing and acting in
non-conformist ways surgical homicide is
trans and queer just the new Punk goth
but I think there are a number of things
and uh you know lumping it all into
Trends doesn't do justice to all of them
and you know we we have been consistent
and persistent in saying sort of true
trans and transrise activists and this
is the vast majority of who we're
hearing from now and you the question
asked her are saying yeah but over in
true trans area isn't isn't it mostly
just being an unconformist
and I do think there's there's some of
that
um but there's also some you know some
known
um actually genetic anomalies which
pretty and you know this this is where
actually trans and and intersex actually
do combine into something related to one
another where uh you can have a genetic
condition where you are born
I don't know if they're these actually
exist going both directions but
um you're born very much looking like
one sex and then when puberty hits it
becomes clear that you are actually
going to manifest as as the other and
um that is that is about a genetic slash
developmental anomaly that you had
nothing to do with and you have no
choice in so that's not just
um dressing acting in unconformist ways
though you know there are Pockets I
believe you know there's one of these
that I've written about
um
that exists in Haiti I believe it is or
is it Dominican Republic I can't
remember which
um one of the countries on Hispaniola
there's a village with a high rate of
this genetic anomaly that results in it
being you know machiambres uh you know
the boy
girls men women
and that's not just about being an
unconformist yeah
um that said how much of how much of
people
really feeling that they are they need
to present to the world in a different
way uh could just as well have
manifested as and you know I'm just
always going to wear purple or something
maybe there's some of that too I also
suspect that
if science and medicine writes itself
and we actually have good solid research
going forward that we are likely to
learn that there are some effects
perhaps dramatic of environmental uh
hormones that have that have gone into
the waterways that are affecting people
that are actually you know that are
actually
um
turning people
into
into realized adults that they wouldn't
otherwise have been absent the hormones
in the water
yep I I agree with all that uh the one
of the one thing I would add is
in the cultures where this is a
recognized and accepted phenomenon
there are
parameters
where a person who is recognized to be
in this category is effectively
shunted into the role of the other sex
for all purposes right in other words
you you know if you are a the equivalent
of a trans woman then you marry as a
woman
and there are I think it's absolutely
fascinating why such a mechanism would
exist but the fact that we've seen it
many many times
um suggested it has a significance it's
not
yeah I guess I'm not um I haven't tried
looking at the anthropological
literature to see how common it actually
is and I am not as compelled as I think
you are that it is common as some people
claim it is I think it definitely exists
in at least a few places but I'm not
sure that it is quite so common as all
of that all right well
I mean I don't know what all that is
let's put it this way if you've got 10
examples of cultures where it exists and
is long-standing as good enough for my
purposes yeah 10 10 strikes me as
um
an interesting number that doesn't
really sound like many many times but
um yeah and I don't I don't even know if
the anthropology exists honestly you
know and how how would you do it now
yeah I don't I don't think it can be
done now so it would have to have been
done historically and of course that
would have been then we'd have to
interpret to the lens of anthropologists
who you know had you know that was that
was way Beyond The Pale you know
homosexuality was beyond the pale most
anthropologists having been male
couldn't even talk to women at all
because most of the receiving cultures
if they received it all wouldn't talk to
male anthropologists so you know what
what we're going to be able to know for
sure is going to be um unfortunately
quite selective yes people would be uh
referencing the literature in the
library the l i e b r a r y Library yes
who would be referencing those who would
claim to study this
no no no
all right I think yes but
does
does transitioning
appeal to our yearning for Resurrection
altering the data in order to start anew
retroactive continuity reboot
um I wouldn't go that far but I would
say I think there's almost no question
just that
people have been handed
people have been betrayed by a society
that has inflicted
foreign
important
destructive compounds on them early in
life has handed them a puzzle in terms
of mating and dating that is unsolvable
has handed them a monotonous reality has
handed them schools that don't educate
basically the point is the number of
reasons that you might feel radically
ill at ease in the present
are many and people lashing about for
answers what is it that you know if you
make the mistake of thinking that other
people are doing all right
and it's just you who's suffering
something must be way way way off maybe
it's my gender right it's not surprising
especially if there's some thing
broadcasting that as an answer you know
what's wrong it's your gender
um it's not surprising that people land
on this and decide maybe that's it
hopefully that's it I can just change
that
right I think that's all true but I
think we've also we're also suffering
from a loss of
um ceremony and ritual Coming of Age
ceremonies almost don't happen anymore
and sort of modern era
opportunities to reinvent yourself don't
really exist anymore either because
social media yep so there there were
many decades there of of modern times
where going off to college or going off
to the Army or going off to work if you
were moving to a new town
allowed you to try on something
different
and now you go and everything that
you've been doing on social media up
until then follows you and it's expected
to be continuous and it's obvious if
you're suddenly a different human being
and so there aren't these really you
know expected predictable I'm looking
forward to it I'm going to plan it I'm
not going to change yet but then I'm
going to try I'm trying to try to be
more outgoing I'm going to try you know
whatever it is people used to be able to
do that and know that they were doing it
and go for it and now there's no escape
from who you are unless you're like
actually I'm not who I am I'm not who I
thought I was I'm not who you thought I
was here I am I'm different and so that
does kind of feel like a resurrection in
some ways that's a really good point
which is you and I agree and have often
said the lack of uh Rites of Passage and
things is a critical failure yeah but
the idea that in a vacuum of such things
you might invent your own and then some
force is out there with has a ready-made
version of it hey here's one and
everybody will understand it and what's
more everybody will have to respect it
because you know because there's a
weapon that will punish those who don't
yeah
um so yeah I think there's a I think
there's a lot to that that this is
a pre-packaged and in most cases phony
mechanism for replacing something that
our
uh and it really is a chesterton's fence
kind of issue we got rid of a bunch of
things that were doing a whole hell of a
lot of work this goes exactly to Aaron
Wright's Point uh in that piece you read
yep right that you know I've made this
point about a couple dancing
all right we this we used to serve a
really important function and it is no
longer
certainly not Universal was rarely done
really in the west and
um lo and behold mating and dating is
[ __ ] up
right does the fact that we took this
ritualized
you know mating and dating
playground and eliminated it in favor of
something else and then mating and
dating got [ __ ] up like maybe those
two things have a relationship with each
other yeah
um so anyway yeah I love your point here
I think people looking for that ability
to um
to reinvent themselves and then having
this one presented to them where there
are no other options
that's a that's a big piece of this
puzzle yeah I think it might be
how long have we been at it Zack
uh about an hour and 10 minutes hour and
10 minutes
let's do two more all right
regarding Sargon the term you're looking
for is Manifest observable Behavior
would love to see him and Brett appear
on each other's shows that wasn't a
question so I'll do two more that's
interesting actually and you know
I wasn't paying a lot of attention to
him before but I felt like patreon kind
of won they kind of they kind of they
kind of quieted him well no no
I think it's not simple because I think
what happened to him
is actually something that frequently
happens
where
the world engages in what is tantamount
to a negotiation with a problem person
I don't consider Sargon a problem person
but but something did right and the
point is how would you like a deal where
you are more prosperous and you are in
charge of what you say and do but the
normies don't hear from you yeah right
and I think it is not changing the
conversation over in normally land right
and I think it does this to people again
and again it's one of the reasons that
it's very difficult to figure out what
to do about something like YouTube or
Twitter which is
going somewhere else even if it
increases your audience may be agreeing
to be neutralized yeah which is what the
thing wants
um yeah
yeah
uh was the cluster fact Festival
transparently intended to hide the truth
I feel like that's
um a question that doesn't need an
answer
um
so much noise does Ivermectin really
work love you guys
that's the final question for today
design really work it works for a lot of
things including including coven
including prophylaxis and against and
treatment for covid but you know what it
doesn't work as well as the propaganda
that has thoroughly confused this issue
yeah why do I say it works I say it
works because even the studies that are
touted as suggesting it doesn't work if
you dig deeply a you see they were
designed to fail B you see that their
own authors actually acknowledge that
the drug Works behind the scenes before
they publish a paper that says publicly
it doesn't work and if you look at the
data and you analyze it independent of
what is written in those papers you also
find an effect so
yeah it's clear that it works it's also
clear that it would be strange if it did
and a lot of the world knows this
right and much of the world is not
living under the Absurd absurd in the
Absurd pharmaceutical landscape that we
are
yeah get it over the counter in many
places and people are doing that when
they get covered yep yeah they are and
you know I guess the thing that is most
fascinating to me
is that we are the least well-informed
people on Earth about this right that we
in the west and in particular in the U.S
are suffering from the most intense
propaganda and so
um those of us who have the advantages
of being from the West would it Be
Imagined to have better information
however noise of the information was
ours would be better nope it's the exact
inverse well we do have fact-checking
festivals though so uh that in in our in
our defense
yes fact-checking festivals headed by
fouchy
yep
p h a u c i yeah yeah
um yeah except that that presumes that
there was an earlier
if I actually spelled with an F that uh
was a
was it more honorable one and I'm not
sure that's true I don't know yeah I
don't know I I hope we ultimately do
find out it would be great yeah all
right well that got grim
maybe it's time for a virtual Festival
on some dry topic of our choosing to yes
make sure they're like there's neither
there's music not music dancing
cocktails anything right real people to
engage with we want a festival that is
limited to typing things
that adhere to a strict code that does
not result in PayPal extracting
thousands of dollars from your account
because you've said twenty five hundred
dollars per infraction you say per
infraction oh my Lord for interfaction
every time that you claim that uh
that
um
Bruce Jenner
[Music]
dead naming is probably an infraction oh
of course it's an infraction you
wouldn't there was no Bruce Jenner there
was never a Bruce Jenner wait there was
never a Bradley Manning so
no one knows who won silver and bronze
in the events
stop sorry about that no one knows who
won silver and bronze in the events that
Bruce Jenner won Gold in but given that
Bruce Jenner apparently doesn't exist
and never did
doesn't the guy who came in Forth
actually need to be notified and get his
medal and the guy who won silver needs
to win gold and the guy who won bronze
needs to win silver doesn't this I mean
isn't that what needs to happen totally
and if there's a women's decathlon then
uh is it Caitlyn Jenner
is that the guy's name at this point I
think so yeah incidentally Caitlyn
Jenner
um is
is
good on this yeah I was actually I was
actually Jenner was actually really saw
it on this like I don't like I do not
respect frankly the dawning the
you know the hyper feminized and
sexualized stuff of Womanhood and saying
that that is what makes you a woman but
Caitlyn Jenner who presents as a woman
and lives
as a woman uh holds no truck with this
like trans
women should be playing against women
and female sports and all this is having
none of it so you know more power to
Caitlyn Jenner more power to Caitlyn
Jenner I also was going to make the same
point this oh nobody's making fun of of
Caitlyn Jenner yeah I'm making fun of
the New York Times I can't figure out
that Bradley Manning was the person who
hand over documents to WikiLeaks right
but I mean I I I don't I don't
appreciate or respect and I don't
remember what crazy fashion magazine put
Caitlyn Jenner on the cover post surgery
it was like Vogue or Cosmo or something
I think and it was it was just you know
hypersexualizes like see how can you
object to this being a woman like
are do we in fact live in the 50s what
happened like when did we start
celebrating hypersexualization of SEC of
the women bearing their secondary sex
characteristics
um some of which they bought in a store
like what the hell uh it was an
inevitable consequence of our eating our
Wheaties w-u-e-e-d-i-e-s
was Jenner one of the one that was Bruce
Jenner one of the guys like pitching
Wheaties was he yeah okay interesting it
was all over that week but he was
actually eating Wheaties no he wasn't
eating Wheaties the people who have
decided that
is the ultimate woman
they are eating Wheaties
all right this has now gotten convoluted
I just don't know what to do
um yeah well I just don't know what to
do welcome to that Festival yeah well
Tesla got the right idea he's going to
stretch and he's going to consider lying
back down the other side that side was
done and now he's yep yeah this side is
oh it's very toasty very nicely done yes
well done okay uh we will see you next
week not a week from now but a week from
tomorrow we won't see them they will see
us
this thing I believe this is an
expression that people use it is it is
it totally is and every time I hear it I
think that's crazy and then I say it and
then I think that's even crazier and
there we are
it sounds presumptuous to say you will
see us I agree it's that's obnoxious
right I assume many of you will and I
appreciate how about this for doing so
but
instead of saying you will see us how
about we start saying we won't see you
next week no
trying to lose audience YouTube side now
we got to do something we'll see you
never
how about that
um no uh
how about this okay we'll see you next
week c-e-e-y-o-u
as opposed to SCE which implies that we
will actually see them
yeah
just now
I was I was hoping you were going to be
more forthcoming about what your
imagined definition of c-e-e is
um C is the metaphorical C in which
we already metaphorical
that's how it's being used this is hyper
metaphor
I think we have now talked ourselves
into a cul-de-sac
[Music]
um
that was mostly you I think I have now
talked ourselves into a cul-de-sac yeah
okay so uh eight days from now we will
be signing off and promising to see you
again next time yep as I am going to do
right now we will see you again next
week in the meantime be good to the ones
you love eat good food and get outside
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]